ok
[Music]
the measures to be taken effectively
they are obviously known to
most citizens, i.e. drink a
lot around 2 liters a day
stay in the shade for as long as possible
avoid efforts during the day, especially for
all those who work  outside
we are very attentive to the construction
sector in the catering sector and and
the bulbs of the employers must
make cooled rooms
available and a lot of water
available
the signs of hyperthermia of
heat stroke arrive very quickly and it is  these
are quite common symptoms,
that is to say it can be
headaches it can be a feeling of
nausea vomiting or
intense fatigue and therefore you have to be attentive
to the symptoms that you feel
from french  gare de mende is organized
juan verzeri you yes sit in aux exactly
what to do it
for example a mania cities two
boats cars fountain stone together
easily sometimes some cities 10 years and
to  postpone on to stop start i want you
haven't been to man to man chris paul
thibault je va très bien
[Music]
no